Salut la Team Mentalo, aujourd'hui j'ai un challenge contre l'intelligence artificielle.
J'ai rendez-vous avec Romain de la chaîne TechNews&Tests
avec comme but de faire aussi bien voire mieux qu'un programme comme Akinator.
Et comme on va faire ça chez lui, le mieux c'est quand même que je vous emmène avec moi.
Comme Romain habite loin, je prend une Autolib, c'est  même pas une Autolib, c'est un four !
36 degrés, impeccable
Bon c'est vrai, le trajet est un petit peu long, alors comme on va chez un geek
pour meubler ce trajet, je vais vous faire des blagues de geek.
Une blague de geek en général, c'est une blague que seuls les geeks comprennent,
et que même quand on t'explique pourquoi c'était drôle, tu comprends toujours pas pourquoi c'est drôle.
Je sais pas ce que ça va donner pour le son, mais je suis obliger d'ouvrir les fenêtres, là, les amis.
Ah ça me change la vie.
J'espère juste que ça va pas pourrir tout le son de la vidéo
et puis c'est bien les blagues, ça évite de s'ennuyer.
D'ailleurs, un geek ne s’ennuie jamais il se fichier
fi-chier
*rires*
Il va y avoir un level dans l'humour
Dans le même état d'esprit, j'en ai un avec 3 ingénieurs qui discutent entre eux.
Ils sont à un salon de l'informatique, ils parlent entre eux et puis...
Le 1er, il dit: "Vous voyez moi, par exemple,
quand je sors des toilettes, je fais comme dans ma société
je suis ingénieur chez Microsoft,
donc je mets pas trop de savon,
pas beaucoup de savon
pas beaucoup d'eau non plus
comme ça je lave les mains très rapidement
donc voilà c'est pas au top de chez au top mais au moins ça coûte pas cher."
Et puis le 2ème ingénieur dit:
"Aaah moi tu vois c'est différent.
Moi je suis ingénieur chez Apple
et au contraire comme dans ma société
quand je sors des toilettes, je mets beaucoup beaucoup de savon, je lésine pas. Je mets beaucoup, beaucoup d'eau
Alors oui, c'est très cher dans le budget mais il y a quand même une bien meilleure qualité quoi
et là, les 2 regarde le troisième, en disant: - Et toi tu travailles où?
" Ah moi je travaille chez Oracle mais je ne peux pas vous aider parce que chez nous on se pisse pas sur les doigts."
Ouh la petite blague où l'on parle de PIPI
Au fait, je suis désolé j'ai ouvert la chemise, mais vraiment parce que je suis en train de cramer.
On sait très bien que j'ai pas de muscles, qu'il y a aucune ambiguïté avec ça.
Il existe 10 types de personnes dans le monde.
Ceux qui connaissent le binaire et les autres
*rires*
Si vous connaissez , vous aussi, des blagues un peu geek hésitez pas à les mettre en commentaire, qu'on en ait plus
Même si elles ne sont pas très drôles, n'hésitez pas parce que vous avez comme point de référence les miennes
vous pourrez pas faire pire que les miennes, en fait, que celles que j'ai faite.
F: Les mecs après une autolib, 3 trains, 2 avions, 1 tram et 1 touc-touc j'ai enfin...
Romain: Tu as oublié le dromadaire
F: Non j'ai pas pris de dromadaire, j'ai pris une autolib au départ
R: Exact
F: Ben oui, pour aller plus vite
R: 2016
F: J'ai enfin retrouvé Romain, dont l'adresse s'affiche
Nulle part
Personne n'a trouvé l'adresse de Romain
R: C'est beau hein?
F: Sauf moi, c'est beau le mentalisme
R: C'est ça. Tu m'as appelé et tu m'as dit "Bouges pas j'arrive"
F: Ouais j'ai fait le 06 *bip*
*réfléchi*
R: Il s'en souvient en plus. C'est ouf
F: Soixante euh...
R: Faut qu'on leur dise comment on s'est rencontré
F: 3
F: On s'est rencontré au Meet up de Pierre Croce
R: C'est exacte
Je ne suis jamais trop allé à la rencontre, tu vois, je suis toujours un peu..
F: C'est vrai?
R: Ouais plus par internet
après ça dépend Youtube, etc. ce qu'ils s'organisaient mais là c'était cool.
F: Moi c'était le 1er Meet up. J'avais jamais fait de Meet up en fait.
Je savais même pas ce que c'était un Meet up quand il m'a dit "Ben tu viens, tu bois"
R: Et tu touches
F: Je suis venu
R: Ouais, voilà c'était, voilà c'était,Voilà en généralement ça commence par tu bois
F: Ouais tu bois... Et j'ai bien respecté la règle. Tu as vu?
*rires*
R: Je suis arrivé. J'ai dit: " Bon du coup tu devines mon numéro et tout." Et ça a donné
[imite Fabien éméché] Ah oui ben oui
Et voilà à partir de là j'ai :  Ah c'est un mec de confiance
F: C'est ça *rires*
R: Faut qu'on fasse une vidéo ensemble
F: Comme toi tu es hyper branché Tech, tu dois aimé les intelligences artificielles.
R: Ouais
R: Ça peut faire flipper parfois mais c' est grave cool à utiliser
F: Bon alors du coup Akinator, tu vois, et Q20 c'est qu'une grosse base de donnée qui séquence un petit peu les réponses etc..
en fait j'aimerai me challenger vis à vis de ça. Tu vois?
J'aimerai me poser le challenge de faire aussi bien, voire même mieux qu'un Akinator
R: Tu insinues donc que l'intelligence artificielle peut être plus intelligente que l'homme est plus rapide, plus furtive?
F: Pas plus intelligente, plus efficace
R: Plus efficace
F: De fait
R: Ouais
F: Une calculatrice est plus efficace qu'un homme
R: Certes, mais quand on se dit que c'est l'homme qui la programmait
F: Exactement c'est pour ça que...
R: Allez Salut
*rires*
F: Tu as déjà réussi à poser une colle toi à Akinator? sans me dire laquelle, juste oui ou non.
un truc qu'il aurait pas trouvé?
R: Je crois oui une fois, c'est quand j'avais 3 abonnés
du coup personne ne me connaissait.
F: Ah tu cherchais ton nom à toi?
R: Voilà
*Rires*
F: Et oui forcément.
R: Qui ne l'a pas fait?
F: TechNews et tests ou TechNews and tests?
R: Ça dépend
Do you know what I am
TechNews and tests
F: A chaque fois que je te téléphone tu dis "TechNews et Tests
R: Je le fais en mode très French.
Tu sais c'est "Bien le bonjour monsieur, bienvenue chez TechNews et Test entreprise"
F: Aujourd'hui des objets rigolos
R: Voilà
F: What the f[U]ck
R: What the f[U]ck
F: Ça va être moi qui fait jouer le rôle d' Akinator
R: Ok
F: Et toi qui va essayer de me poser une colle.
Est ce que tu veux qu'on parte sur...
R: J'ai que de la UHU par contre
F: Ne...
R: Pffff c'est nul
R: J'ai honte
F: Ça m'a coûté 3 billets d'avion, donc je reviens.
Mais c'est vraiment pour rentabiliser la vidéo tu vois
parce qu'en ce moment je suis en flux tendu c'est la vidéo de demain j'ai pas le choix ok?
F: Tu préfères un personnage célèbre?
*Réfléchis*
célèbre dans le sens où la majorité des gens doivent le connaitre
R: Ouais c'est bon
C'est bon je suis chaud
F: A part toi même
R: Ouais *rire* Le mec qui est vraiment lourd tu sais.
F: Ou est ce que tu préfères qu'on parte sur un objet un truc comme ça?
R: On peut partir sur une célébrité
F: Sur une célébrité, donc ça c'est plus Akinator
Tu vois les objets c'est plus le Q20
R: Ouais
Tu vois ce que c'est le Q20?
R: Non
F: Je... je vais vous le mettre en insert là quelque part.
C'est l'espèce de petite boule que tu peux acheter.
Ça ressemblait à un tamagotchi géant si tu veux. Et...
R: Ouiiii
F: Tu vois?
R: Oui oui je vois la boule, oui je vois
F: Et en 20 questions, il te posait 20 questions
R: C'était ça
F: Il te retrouvait ton objet en fait
R: C'était le 1er truc, c'est vrai que ça avait démarré là dessus
F: Moi j'avais A-doré ça
R: C'est pas mal ça
F: Je trouvais ça passionnant et...
et sur papier, j'avais pas d'ordi à l'époque, je m'amusais à refaire les arborescences pour comprendre comment il avait stocké...
Oui...
Faut savoir que je rentre les télécommandes dans l'ordre chez moi
R: D'accord
F: Je suis un peu monomaniaque
R: Tu es le genre de mec à faire un scrabble tout seul un dimanche après midi quand il pleut c'est ça?
F: Ouais *rires*
R: Et essayer de comprendre comment ton cerveau a pu prévoirl'ancien mot
Le mec se cherche encore tout seul en fait
Tu sais Claude François disait "Chaque détails compte"
F: Et après il a dit : "Arghhh"
R: C'est ça
F: "argh"
R: Au moins il a rejoint la lumière
F: Et depuis l'ambiance est électrique
R: Olala [Applaudis]
F: On fait un battle, on oublie Akinator, on fait un battle
Un battle de vannes.
Non on va revenir sur Akinator
Je vais me décaler
Tu vas l'écrire, tu leur fais voir à eux
R: Depuis l'année 96 je crois, lors de mon année de naissance j'ai pas revu un bouquin, enfin un petit calepin comme ça
F: Un petit Rhodia, tu avais pas vu un petit Rhodia
R: Non non ça m'avait manqué
F: Moi j'ai pleins de cahiers avec moi si tu veux, je t'ouvrirai un cahier avant de partir
F: Euh... je vais me mettre là comme ça, tu peux confirmer que je ne vois pas cet écran ici là
R: D'accord
F: Cet écran de contrôle
R: D'accord, ok
F: Toi tu l'écris de manière lisible
R: Ok
F: Tu leur fais voir
F: Tu prends la feuille, tu l'arraches et tu la mets derrière toi sous un coussin
R: Donc là je suis censé marqué le prénom
F: Ou que le nom de famille par exemple, en fait la chose qui permet de mieux l'identifier quoi
R: D'accord
F: C'est la preuve
F: Donc vous, vous le saurez mais pas moi et je peux vous assurer que je ne vois pas l'écran de contrôle
R: De toute façon on triche pas.
Pas chez TechNews&Tests enterprise
F: Je parle en même temps parce qu'il y en a qui pense que je peux entendre le bruit du crayon sur le papier
Rigole pas je peux le faire
Je m'attends à tellement tout.
En fait, il y avait un sale sourire sur ton visage quand tu m'as dis que tu en avais un.
Tu le dessines ou tu l'écris?
[Romain: Rires]
R: Attends bouges pas.
*rires*
F: C'est que tu le fais voir aux autres c'est ça?
R: Chut
C'est bon, alors attends maintenant je vais enlever le papier
F: Tu l'arraches
R: Attends d'abord faut que j'enlève le bouchon, c'est très compliqué tu sais c'est... j'ai pas fait d'études donc c'est très compliqué à reboucher un bouchon. Voilà
Reboucher un bouchon en 2016 Romain, bien joué
Je l'arrache, je le mange c'est ça?
F: Oui tu le caches derrière toi dans une poche, quelque chose
R: Ok
R: Je le cache
F: C'est bon je peux revenir?
R: Tu peux revenir
R: Il y a plus rien
F: Super
F: Vous l'avez vu vous?
[De derrière la caméra] Ouais
F: Parce qu'il faut quand même savoir qu'il y a un public ici
R: C'est ça
F: Tu tournes toujours en public comme les sitcoms.
Tu sais comme les vieux sitcoms, comme ça quand il fait une vanne, une vanne bien merdique.
R: Tu entends le [Rires enregistrés] à l'arrière horrible tu sais
R: Mais alors un truc bête, tu voulais pas en même temps que je joue à Akinator?
F: Alors, si j'aimerai bien que tu le fasse et qu'on voit qui gagne, en fait, exactement
R: Ok, après je vais refaire du coup je vais essayer de faire deviner à Akinator
F: La même chose
R: Ok d'accord, ça roule
F: Si tu as envie de prononcer le nom vas y dit le
R: Non rien du tout, c'est pour ça que je me bloque
F: *rires*
R: Je ne dis rien, je ne dirai rien
F: Tu as un téléphone, un truc là?
R: Ouais mon téléphone il est où?
F: Va le chercher c'est pas très grave, je ferai une coupe.
F: euh... vas y fait à la sienne, il y a pas de problème
R: Ok
R: Je montre à la caméra?
F: Oui, vas y
F: C'est bon tu as répondu?
R: C'est bon j'ai répondu
F: Ok, voici ma question: "est ce que c'est une femme?
Je pense que c'est une femme par rapport à la question que je t'ai posé
et à la réaction que tu as eu tout à l'heure. Alors j'ai besoin de confirmer
R: Oui
F: Oui ok cool
R: Alors ensuite
Ok. à toi
F: Vous avez vu que je ne le regarde pas parce que eux ils savent que je décode le non verbal en permanence, donc j'ai pas envie de tricher je la joue honnête.
*réfléchis*
Est ce que c'est issue de... l'univers des écrans. C'est à dire au sens large, cinéma, YouTube, télévision?
R: Oui
F: Ok
R: Ok
F: Est ce que... cette femme... est fictive ou est ce qu'on parle d'une actrice, d'une comédienne?
Est ce qu'on parle d'un nom propre ou d'un personnage?
R: Attends, refait ta question il y a eu trop de bruit derrière.
F: Est ce qu'on parle d'un personnage ou est ce qu'on parle de l'actrice en elle même?
Est ce qu'on parle d'un personnage?
R: Non
F: Non donc de l'actrice en elle même
R: Tu as une 2ème question parce que j'ai répondu déjà à une autre question d'Akinator
F: Tu es tellement rapide
R: Tu sais moi et la technologie
F: Est ce que c'est issue d'une série télévisée?
R: Non
R: A toi
à toi
[Chuchote] ça te stresse?
[Chuchote] ça te stresse
F: Est ce que la 1ère lettre
du prénom
ou de son nom, de ce qui viens spontanément quand on pense à cette personne
Est ce que la 1ère lettre, dans l'alphabet, est située après la lettre M
F: Ou avant.
Donc ma question est: "est ce que c'est situé après?"
R: *rires*
F: [Fait roulement de tambour]
F: Arh s'il fallait connaitre son alphabet, j'ai pas révisé non plus *rires*
[Rires enregistrés]
*Rire de Fabien]
R: Après
R: A toi
R: Akinator est plus rapide à répondre
F: Ouais mais... il est moins fort que moi au final !
F: Est ce que la 1ère lettre c'est un "T" ?
R: Non
F: C'est tout
F: Est ce que c'est un "R" ?
R: Oui
F: Moi j'ai une proposition
donc je vais l'écrire ici
R: Donc là je réponds encore à une question?
F: Tu vas jusqu'au bout d'Akinator mais moi on sait que j'ai...
Et compte le nombre de question qu'il te pose en plus
R: Là j'en suis à la 9ème. Donc une,
La deuxième, ton personnage a t'il
R: Je vous fais voir, je changerai pas
F: C'est long Akinator *rires*
R: Tu as vu je fais comme les bébés, je fais comme ça pour compter 4.
*rires de Fabien*
F: Il est long, il est long
R: Ouais c'est long hein, ouais je suis déjà à plus de 6 questions.
F: C'est vrai
R: Ça va nous soûler.
F: Alors à qui tu pensais?
R: Non je veux d'abord...
F: Je leur ai fait voir, je ne pourrais pas changer, je leur ai fait voir.
Je leur ai fait voir ce que j'ai écrit
*rires*
F: Voilà il y aura pas de... "changeage" possible
R: Margot Robbie
F: D'accord, je ne connais pas elle fait quoi?
R: C'est celle qui a joué dans le dernier film Suicid Squad
F: Ah non, j'aurai jamais pu penser que tu aurais pris ça
F: Margot Robbie
R: Ouais
F: Tu veux voir le papier?
R: Vas y
F: J'ai peur que ça t'énerve après
F: J'ai tellement peur que ça t'énerve
F: J'ai juste marqué Robbie, directement si ça dérange personne.
Est ce qu'on peut faire un petit comparatif s'il vous plait
R: Roh pétard
R: Comme c'est possible.
*Rire de Fabien*
[Personne derrière la caméra]: Je sais pas, il m'a montré le truc j'ai fait ça.
*Fabien rire*
R: Comment c'est possible.
*rire de Fabien et de la personne présente*
R: Tu m'as proposé que 2 lettres
F: En fait après je...
Moi j'ai un avantage qu'Akinator n'aura jamais sur moi
c'est que... c'est que je vois le temps que tu mets à choisir quelqu'un dans ta tête
je vois le sourire que tu as eu ou pas.
Je connais l'actualité ou pas.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Je sais que tu as fait, plus ou moins, dernièrement ou pas.
Je sais l'envie que t'as de me piéger ou pas.
Et après je tente un coup de bluff aussi quoi
R: Bon j'ai... j'ai mis que Margot Robbie c'était égale à quelque chose sur mon papier. Est ce que tu arrives à...
si tu te concentre sur moi ou autre est ce que tu arrives...
J'ai... j'ai mis que Margot Robbie en gros
F: Ouais
R: Quand tu pensais à elle ou que tu l'as voyait ça signifie quelque chose
R: J'ai mis Margot Robbie est égale
Et ensuite j'ai fait un petit signe en dessous de ce "est égale"
est égale j'ai écris quelque chose et en dessous de ça j'ai fait un petit signe
F: donc tu as voulu nous faire rire
R: Exactement
F: Ça c'est obligé
F: euh...
F: Je sais pas si j'étais Tibo Inshape je dirais "Meule"
R: Roh Put***
oh put*** j'ai mis Boobs
*Rire de Fabien*
R: Oh non mais non
F: Je veux voir le dessin
R: C'est ouf
*rires*
R: J'ai mis Robbie = Boobs avec un coeur quoi mais c'est ouf
F: J'ai battu Akinator.
ok
on a la preuve ici
même 6 questions après il l'avait toujours pas.
[Romain applaudis]
R: C'est ouf
F: Donc comme quoi
R: Non franchement c'est ouf
F: Comme quoi on a bouclé la boucle,
ok l'homme a crée l'intelligence artificiel mais il garde quand même le pouvoir de déduction sur lui si il veut
ou pas.
R: Ah je suis entièrement... non je suis entièrement d'accord là dessus
mais c'est ouf quand même de...
après lui il fonctionne avec une base de donnée
F: C'est ça
R: C'est ce que tu disais, il ne fonctionne pas avec les émotions, avec l'actualité et autres
F: Ouais jamais
R: Mais tu as dû bien suivre mon actualité pour savoir... enfin... je trouve ça... enfin 2 questions concrètes c'était les lettres
et tu as proposé "T", tu as proposé "R" direct après
"R" il y avais pleins d'autres trucs de possible tu vois
Ah franchement c'est bluffant quoi
F: Ça te plait
R: Ouais grave
F: Cool je suis tellement content de l'avoir fait avec toi, ça faisait longtemps, en fait, que je voulais faire le Battle, comme ça, avec Akinator
R: Et c'est pas mal en plus
F: Avec toi c'était cool. Tu vois !
R: Moi qui ne sait pas trop utiliser les smartphones et tout ça. Ça tombait bien comme ça j'ai appris à utiliser un smartphone dans cette vidéo.
*rires*
F: Bon ce qu'on a fait ça s'appelle du Stock Reading, je te le dis en mentalisme.
Je vous ferais une vidéo la dessus sur le stock reading,
c'est à dire le... d'avoir un gros paquet comme ça d'information et de faire un entonnoir pour accéder à une information
je vous fera ça peut être, pas ce dimanche là, mais je le ferais ça un dimanche
sur comment... sur, on va dire, un choix limité à 100 données vous pouvez en quelques questions trouver la donnée que la personne a choisi
R: C'est grave cool en tout cas. Merci de m'avoir invité pour cette expérience.
F: Merci Mec écoute c'est cool, j'étais jamais venu, comme ça, du côté de la Croatie
F: Oh la vache
R: C'est beau hein?
F: J'ai dit, j'ai dit Croatie
R: C'est magnifique
F: On est en Croatie les mecs
R: Vous avez vu c'est un peu ouf
F: Dans un appartement volant, là on vient de passer la Bulgarie, on redescend vers l'Ukraine, cesoir on est à Yalta. Demain c'est
R: C'est un jet privé
*rire*
Demain Sébastopol
*rires*
F: On traverse la mer noire, on fini en Turquie
impeccable
Voilà c'est le seul endroit de géographie où je peux te dire comme ça
*rires*
F: Merci beaucoup. Et si jamais vous connaissez pas Romain de la chaîne TechNews&Tests, je vous invite à cliquer sur son visage.
et à regarder dans le descriptif, je vais mettre un lien, vers ta chaîne. C'est une chaîne...
R: Avec plaisir
F: Cool
R: Si jamais vous connaissez pas Fabien, puisque vous le retrouvez grâce aux partages que vous avez vu de partout et que vous avez vu sa petite tête, là toute mignonne
que vous ne connaissez pas non plus, vous pouvez aller voir sa chaîne
et pour le coup vous êtes déjà dessus
mais pas vraiment, donc allez sur sa chaîne et vous allez voir les autres vidéos qu'il a fait.
il a tourné aussi avec mon pote qui est Pierre Croce.
F: Oui avec Pierre
R: Vous avez fait des trucs cool ensemble et c'est comme ça qu'on s'est connu. C'est magnifique.
F: Exactement
R: Et on n'eurent beaucoup d'enfants
F: Alors toi peut être
R: Peut être. Voilà. Allez
F: Si jamais vous avez aimé la vidéo, bin, c'est cool *rires* et vous pouvez nous le faire savoir en nous laissant un petit pouce en l'air
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir et rendez vous demain à 17h
Ciao !